Speaker 1: All right. Let's go through a couple
of things. I've been saving up this week and just
didn't really have time for until today. As many
of you know, we've been following the supposed
bankruptcy of Infowars conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones, where he says they don't really
have any money, but then they got two $1 million
Bitcoin donations and now they've got 5 million,
but they still don't have enough money to pay
any of the Sandy Hook parents in the settlement
that they filed and won against Alex Jones for
defamation. It's all a complete and total mess.
Alex Jones seemed to almost have like a medical
event, almost like stroking out or having a
cardiac event during his show where he seemed
to be saying they are in a war. They I don't
know if they is Infowars or the American right
wing or who they are in a war. And the only way
to win the war is for you to buy his products,
including his supplements, and to send him money.
This is really full on stuff.
It's simultaneously hilarious,
but also extraordinarily weird.
Speaker 2: And supporting our guest because
everybody we have on is fighting with every.
Speaker 3: Day they've got, whoa.
Speaker 4: This is a war.
Speaker 2: Against you and
your family of inflation and.
Speaker 1: Collapse. It's
really like a tri decaf type of moment here.
Speaker 2: And they know everybody's going to
wake up in the midst of this war. They want to
silence the leaders because they think they can
then defeat you. So when you keep us in the
fight, you keep yourself in the fight. And this
is life or death, right? To go to Infowars,
Tor.com and get amazing products and sign a
partnership and support, make a donation top and
go to the Stone Defense Fund to make a donation
to him because he's a gladiator and a champion.
Speaker 1: And now they have supplements up on
the screen, energy supplements
and stuff like that fight.
Speaker 2: And if you don't support us, you're
helping the enemy. And I'm not bitching at
Lester's. I'm telling you, this is.
Speaker 4: All I care.
Speaker 3: Roger. Well, I think
you're absolutely right about.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Alex Jones agrees with the
globalist internationalist Trotskyite socialist.
Unlike Obama, Trudeau, Macron and
the rest of the Zio Bish bitch.
That's my Alex Jones impression from. From last
year. This is absolutely hilarious. But also,
we really need to make sure that everybody
following the bankruptcy proceedings is
aware of what's going on here. You know, this
whole like we will only win this moral war
if you buy my supplements and contribute to
my personal finances, which I claim I don't
even have because I said I'm bankrupt. It's it's
beyond parody at this point in time. And there is,
you know, even though Alex Jones Alex Jones does
kowtow to religion to some degree, but it's not as
overtly a religious show as some others. The
supplement stuff. It's starting to remind me
of those evangelical TV shows that sell the
food storage, the mad, the buckets of food.
This is Jim Baker offering buckets
and it's basically like a less manic
Alex Jones. This is the most.
Speaker 3: Unique survival food.
This is 52 servings, right? Turkey feast.
Ooh. Emergency food supply. That's right.
Speaker 1: And this food is.
Speaker 3: 30 years shelf life. It is even has.
Speaker 1: By the way, one of the things I love
is that he says it has a 30 year shelf life,
but at the bottom of the screen, it says
it has a 20 year shelf life. It's like,
wait, so does it last 20 years or 30 years?
Speaker 3: Ken Pie moves for dessert. It does.
We made it the other day and it's super
delicious, actually. I love about Goodbye.
Speaker 1: Pumpkin Pie Mousse.
I've never even heard of that.
It has honey wheat rolls, green bean.
Speaker 3: Casserole, like a lot of you make.
Speaker 1: I have to tell you, the green
bean casserole and the pumpkin pie mousse
look basically the same turkey gravy, seasoned
stuffing, freeze, dried turkey. The freeze dried
turkey does look like dogfood. Mashed potatoes.
Speaker 3: Do this for your survival food.
This is.
Speaker 1: To have. Isn't that the
best? The apocalypse is coming. We are about to be
raptured. But you'll be able to enjoy a completely
typical Thanksgiving dinner thanks to my turkey
feast survival food bucket. It's the same thing
as with the Alex Jones segment, right? It's we're
in a war here and they're trying to silence you
and they're trying to silence me. And the way to
fight it is by buying supplements on my website.
It's like a stupidity test. I saw a cartoon with
a vending machine and the vending machine said,
if you think the election was rigged, insert $100.
And it's sort of the same stupidity if you think.
Alex Jones It's a stupidity test. If you think
buying Alex Jones supplements will save America,
then just send him money. And if you pass the
test, you get to keep your money. It's really
a tragedy of education that people fall for
this stuff in the United States to the tune of
millions of dollars. And as far as the
bankruptcy proceedings with Alex Jones,
hopefully they're paying attention to
everything that's happening with this business.